you know sometimes you walk into a movie
and you feel as if your own personal
happiness for the next few days is
riding on whether or not the movie is
good or not that was me walking into
edge of tomorrow edge of tomorrow is
directed by Doug Liman and stars Tom
Cruise Emily Blunt and Bill Paxton in
the future humans are on the edge of
extinction we're in the middle of this
war with this alien race we have these
mech like suits of armor that can assist
us in our battle Tom Cruise plays a
character who accidentally gets infected
with part of this alien gene of some
kind that allows him to relive the exact
same day over and over again in which he
has to try to get better and better and
better at winning this battle where
mankind is in the balance he meets up
with Emily Blunt who is the only other
person who this happened to once before
and they team up to try to figure out a
way to not only stop his problem but win
the war against the aliens now walking
into this movie I was thinking a few
things Doug Liman Bourne Identity loved
Bourne Identity excellent movie great
franchise starter however his style of
action for Bourne Identity was very
quick very shaky and it was one of the
only times that I felt that shakey cam
actually worked I didn't really think
that style would go that well with this
type of science fiction epic the other
thing I was thinking is Tom Cruise
always commits to his action roles he's
very good with stunt work and it gives a
hundred percent to his role so I know
will at least be good in the movie but I
was worried that it looked too much like
oblivion the movie was gonna be too much
like a video game in a bad way I had to
say edge of tomorrow is one of the most
surprising movies I've ever seen in my
life this is a truly excellent science
fiction movie and when I say excellent I
mean this is a great fan-freaking-tastic
science fiction movie in the vein of
films like Terminator aliens Groundhog
Day Minority Report and the game Halo if
I were to best describe this movie would
be like Minority Report combined with
Halo the best aspects of both of them
combined into one I implore you guys to
see this movie on its opening weekend
because I don't feel like this movie is
going to make the amount of money it
deserves edge of tomorrow blew me away
it is a non-stop action film from
beginning to end
was incredibly entertaining while at the
same time being very funny the humorous
aspects of the film were largely because
of the fact that he has to relive the
same day over and over again and you
would think that would drag or would get
repetitive and he'd be like okay I get
it he's done the same stuff before but
the fact that they went for the comedy
of the situation and the way they edited
those scenes were so funny that it
really made the film actually incredibly
enthralling as a thriller and as a
comedy they found the best ways to make
these repetitious scenes entertaining
and they did an excellent job doing that
now I mentioned the Doug Liman style for
Bourne Identity was something that
worried me because I didn't think that
style would match well with this film
thankfully he does not use that type of
editing style in this movie there's a
lot of really great long takes big
action shots wide panning shots of
things that just look incredibly awesome
to see and the special effects in the
film are terrific the aliens in the film
were also really well-done they looked
very erratic like they were like cocaine
addicts or something and I really liked
the way they were portrayed in the movie
now you're thinking man Chris you're
really praising this movie a lot you've
given a lot of really good grades this
year this year is really great so far
and I gotta be honest with you this is
one of the best movies of the year edge
of tomorrow is a non-stop action film
with a great performance from Tom Cruise
I mean there is a shot in this movie
where Tom Cruise freakin rolls for like
50 feet down this hill and then right
into frame and you're like he did that
that's crazy guys in his 50s no actor at
the level of Fame that he is and the age
that he is commits to the action as much
as he does you can just tell he just
wants the audience to have a really good
experience and you feel that in this
role because not only is he very funny
in this movie but he really sells the
drama of the movie and I love the
chemistry between him and Emily Blunt
who was also completely badass in this
movie one of the coolest badass women
roles I have seen in a movie in a very
long time she sold all of her action
scenes as well Bill Paxton was great in
the movie too he was very funny and he
was like if the character from aliens
was still around thirty years later and
he was more hardened like that's what he
would be like now but one of the most
surprising elements to the film I will
not spoil it for you because I want you
to be surprised by it as well even
though it's in the first 10 minutes of
the movie had to do with Tom Cruise's
character he is most definitely not the
type of character that he is promoted as
in
trailers he has a serious arc in this
movie that was very impressive to me and
made me care about his character way
more than you might think if you just
watched a 2 minute trailer for this
movie edge of tomorrow blew me away the
action in the film is terrific
the suspense and the tension of the
third act is so palpable the music is
great the performances are excellent Tom
Cruise does a great job with the action
scenes as does Emily Blunt this movie is
a humungous surprise if you guys want to
have a white-knuckled fun experience at
the movies where you leave and you feel
like your palms are sweaty check out
edge of tomorrow it's definitely worth
your time I honestly can't think of any
major negatives with this movie I'm not
going to give it my perfect grade but I
will give it an A guys when you see this
film let me know because I really do
think it is one of the best straight up
science fiction action films we've had
in years
as always guys thank you so much for
watching this and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck man
eyes